knight c3 b5 and look at magnus's face we miss
it i'm wondering yeah he is not happy at all
yes panko is looking to beat
world champion magnus carlson
this is a historical moment for him it is
just groundbreaking if he wins this game
he will be one of the only players to have
a winning record against magnus carlson
and as i mentioned earlier magnus carlsen did not
lose a class of game chess for 125 games the guy
is hard to take down and in his first opportunity
andre isapenko is about to do the unthinkable
that's amazing that's just amazing
historic moment he stopped the clock 18
year old grandmaster andrei yasipanko
just beat the world champion in a classical game
and look at him that he is exhausted from
the fight that he just brought to the world
champion
one of the best day in my life yes i
feel very great and i have nothing to
say